I see bad decisions as decisions that
were bad with the information available
so it was like not buying Bitcoin in
2013 a bad decision no because I didn't
have the information so there's a
company we invested in as seed Capital
purely in an idea nine months later the
company is now making money but I hated
a lot about it despite now the company
making money and doing revenue and all
these other things I decided not to buy
in like re-up six months later I said I
fix all of these things the third time
it made sense again I was making
different bets the first bet was just
maybe this will become something the
second one is like wow now that I have
more information I actually know there's
way more risks because I understand it
now later he had resolved all of these
things and so then I was like actually
on a risk-adjusted basis this is a lower
risk thing because we've adjusted all
these pieces to it